après trois jours de route nous
atteignons enfin kharkiv la deuxième but
d'ukraine elle est située au nord-est du
pays à 40 km environ de la frontière
avec la russie kharkiv est une scie des
martyrs constamment bombardée depuis
maintenant cinq semaines par les troupes
de vladimir poutine
au bon beurre yeux sont frappés dans
absolument toutes la ville d'après la
mairie de kharkiv environ 1500 bâtiments
ont été détruits ou endommagés par
l'artillerie et russes dont plus d'une
centaine de crèches et d'écoles il y à
au moins 300 morts civils pour l'instant
probablement beaucoup plus car une
grande partie des corps sont encore sous
les décombres
nous sommes ici devant un bâtiment
symbolique qui te derrière moi le siège
du conseil régional de la région de
kharkiv au tout début de l'invasion
russe ou tir de missile balistique avait
ciblé ce monument cette frappe avait été
vu dans le monde entier car elles
avaient été filmés par des caméras de
sécurité et massivement partager sur les
réseaux sociaux elle avait montré toute
la puissance de feu déployée par
vladimir poutine afin de soumettre
l'ukraine
oh
audard et
car qu'il comptait environ un million et
demi d'habitants aujourd'hui plus de 30
% auraient fui la ville ce qui reste
passent une partie de leur vie sous
terre pour échapper aux bombardements le
métro est devenue un immense dortoir
tous les soirs ils sont des milliers à
venir s'y réfugier l'heure du couvre-feu